so only some guys literally 100 yards
right onto Peters deal I have goosebumps
it's it's like 5:00 in the morning
obviously as you guys know I do it on
the weekends I cannot believe what
happened yeah besides I just I just
dropped the
the sister home she just accepted this
she accepted Islam in the car and let me
let me just tell you guys won't be in
our lives it's so overwhelming it's so
overwhelming I get a request yeah so
trade forger I get requests I'm feeling
before sleeping when I feel asleep I'm
heading home
yeah anyways I get a request a semi
destination towards my house yeah so we
need a new bomb set your decision was
the house so its entry jobs that way
so obviously before I ring to see where
the person's going you know to see if it
was exactly my direction so I ring the
sister finishes called Veronica she's
from Lithuania and I just ring and I go
yeah hi they super driver I was just
wondering basically where are you going
she was that something that I was
thinking okay but she said something
else okay anyways I go to pick up I go
there to pick her up
and obviously my fish was at a party and
obviously I feel she was drinking so I'm
waiting three four minutes and rebook
cancels the right after six minutes
so initially she calls me and then I go
okay hi yeah I'm here where are you and
then she goes okay I'm stuck there's
gates I can't open the gates
yeah and I was I was about to cancel
yeah I was gonna forget this seriously
it's not for five minutes it's been for
five minutes I need to go home so I'm
like okay so where are you so I go and I
see there's these guys she's behind
those gates
and she's stuck so she's saying can you
help me and I was like okay almost like
I don't know how to like do a I'm trying
to say like huh I would say now help me
get over the gay and I was like I can't
do that
but anyway it's hunting lateralis
Rantala I said there's usually a button
on that side so she goes okay
and I go okay there's a box there I go
system it may be pressed up
but button there and the doors would
open and she goes she goes and checks it
boom under lock the doors open
she comes in my car I put the
destination it's like 45 minutes and I'm
thinking oh my gosh I'm gonna fall
asleep I can't take I don't know when I
stop halfway and I can't drink coffee
either cuz I'm fasting and so she don't
see my car and I'm heading but in my
head I'm thinking but feeling so sleepy
and she goes are you a Muslim sister and
she goes okay she goes you know and she
was a fasting over here yeah I'm fasting
she was I wanted to fast this month bar
patron because of you know drinking
and she goes I just love Islam I kind of
lost that waking up and I was like okay
wow that's that's quite profound she's
like you know I fell in love with the
religion I love everything about it
I want to move to Abu Dhabi to get away
from my bad friend I was like she wants
to she wants to move to another country
in Islamic country just still stay away
from her bad friend and get closer to
Allah and she's not even a Muslim she's
not a Muslim I was like okay this is
interesting I was like carry on and then
she was like that you know she's really
you know she conflict depression I she
was feeling suicidal and you know that
her I hope she forgives me she might see
this video hopefully yes use me
there's nothing explicit but like she's
a father was killed
etc and you know there's certain things
that she went in her life
etc etc and I was just telling ago you
know because that depression sister is
you know that's that's Allah says in the
Quran you know 1100
weakly laughs and be victory laughs he
thought oh my so I recited and she was
like can you see that again
so recently again and what does that
mean then I said what that means Allah
says in the Quran that only with the
remembrance of Allah do have hearts find
peace I said we feed the body give it
food everything why does the body needs
that to survive but what about the soul
so anyway so I'm just talking to I'm
done I'm just done
Wow like this is the total of Allah this
is destiny I don't believe in chances I
do dower I said it's just I do doubt
that means invited me to some I do this
for like an living like this what I do
you know I do not living but I can
before it inshallah
and I was like Allah sent me to you and
at this time and I was feeling sleepy
that's totally gone and you are here
telling me that you love Islam you love
the religion and I was just
flabbergasted saying okay and then I was
just trying out the internal system you
believe in Allah she goes yeah uncle
you're a Muslim that's not me in my
heart I know I love dark chocolate yeah
what I have to do is testify and say I
love dark chocolate that's that's all it
and she was just asking questions and
she was like you know but you know I I
still have a bad habit of drinking and
etc and I can't be a Muslim here and I
was like this is from Shaytan sister
this is from Shaytan
this is [ __ ] done you can be a
Muslim you can be Muslim this is just a
gradual step as long as you come to
Islam
these are gradual steps things that you
can get rid of slowly I know people
started into them couple of years to get
over to get get get away but this
shouldn't stop you this should not stop
you and subhanAllah brothers and sisters
does me when it comes to Shahada I don't
like for some people I don't like that
kind of trophy Shahada yeah this person
in my whole in Dawa I think about three
or four others yeah because I don't
wanna get someone take this Chadha and
then they don't usually believe in it
this sister she was she was ready she
was up she was like I believe in Allah I
believe in the Prophet SAW sir she was I
went to a job interview and in a job
interview I was praying to Allah I was
an sister you are a Muslim you just ask
you just have to testify and anyways
then afterward she was not just said to
her sister you just need to testify and
she took my Shahada in the car 6s is
5:27 a.m. as I'm doing this video is
5:27 a.m. she took her Shahada 20
minutes ago in the car look at the
pattern of almost Hannah wood
a lot brought me to her I'm not brought
me to her with applause panettone picked
her up from a party picked up from a
party you know and the love that she had
screws I want to go a seat to a stop I'm
gonna get in contact with good sisters
gonna teach you how to pray once that
Iman enters the heart the depression
that you have etc and obviously we know
sometimes people have different
depression of different reasons and the
same this is just the cure for it you
will you would not find anything like it
and she took a Shahada and subhanAllah
like it's unbelievable
III come right now it just feels so
surreal and handing us a sister from now
on you're a Muslim you're a Muslim
you've just gone you've just opened up
Keith Scott the key and you've opened
the door now the journey awaits you you
know and she was just talking and super
honest she was even mentioning like the
wisdom shoot other times she went in to
hear about like polygamy and stuff like
that and she was like you know that you
know she was with some people in our
lives our partners etc and that they
would always cheat on her and she goes
that you know how polygamy is dead
you're not Muslim here and no people
here and indestructible life is
something that puts off any female like
okay our don't forget that and she's
there like I understand that it makes so
clear since this was just so powerful
guys I just really wanted to share this
with you guys
it was unbelievable and may Allah bless
her may Allah keep her firm I'm actually
thinking inshallah I'm gonna get a
sister involved his Wallisch Allah
someone from our team to get involved
and send this sister-in-law my synthesis
of the Umbra in this video I might
actually do requests of Cain I don't
think she requires the funds but as a
gift if there is any Omer organization
that's watching this this sister needs
to go home rock it's going to change her
life it is going to change her life and
she said that she was an actor and etc
etc and she has it Muslim friends she
had Muslim friends you know
Wow and some of the Muslim friends were
thinking okay here you you know you want
to accept Islam because there's some guy
in your lives a Muslim guy she's that
there's no one in my life
no Muslim no grown guy in my life it's
not cause - cause because I love this
religion because this religion is
beautiful
look at this at the middle of the night
morning
I I pick her up long journey even add
hour just talking to her and I'm doing
in love they have a blessing we have a
guy do you guys need to make dua
inshallah
I'm gonna be in contact with the cistern
shell obviously flu I'm gonna get
citizen volved as well and I was just
telling that you know the beauty about
Islam and the rides
you know just telling us is to be
careful you know with it as your Muslim
now you know that there's some men out
there who you know as bad man out there
be careful I said any man and we cover
this you know in the documentaries were
problem sisters do not trust unless they
come and speak to your father or you
whether maybe you're worried you know
and there is there to protect you sister
the shoes just that this is this is so
beautiful the fact that these measures
are in place is so beautiful she say
brothers and sisters were why it's been
absolutely
almost words please keep her in your
doors insha'Allah may Allah bless her
and keep her firm and that's it as such
one share that one like I was
half-asleep I was like wow wow that's it
guys inshallah if I do do the Umrah
thing to raise funds for her I'll put
the link in the description put up the
box below Allah look how look how a
largest can't believe she took Shahada